- Good morning believe nation,
today's message is, get up,
over to you, Bill Clinton.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
♫ I wake every morning
- If whatever it is
doesn't work out, get up.
I lost two elections, I was the youngest
former governor in American History.
(audience laughs)
After the Reagan landslide,
I had one guy appointed to the cabinet,
walk across Main St. in Little Rock,
to avoid being seen shaking hands with me
for fear that the guy that
beat me would fire him.
That was a humbling experience.
And I think you got to realize,
there's no personal ambition you have,
which can be extinguished by anybody else.
Only you, by giving up your
dreams, can extinguish them.
And if it doesn't work out
exactly like you intended,
it'll still take you
someplace interesting,
and you'll make a difference.
So my advice is what George said,
don't be afraid to fail,
but you probably will
whether you're afraid to or not.
And it's scary, you just got to get up.
The world belongs to
tomorrow, not yesterday.
Don't give anybody else
permission to take your life away.
Just keep living and keep giving,
and never make the perfect enemy to good.
Never think that what I'm doing
is too little to make a difference.
That's not true, that's not true.
Do something every day.
Someday, for all of us,
it'll be our last day.
And what will matter were all the steps
we took along the way,
and what they amounted to.
Not the home run we hit on day x.
- Your setback is only
a failure if you quit.
Your setback is only
If you look at the most
successful people in
the world they had tons of setbacks.
They had setback after setback
after setback after setback.
And then they started to win.
And then they had more setbacks
and then they won some more.
That's part of the journey,
there's nobody who wakes up, is born,
and just wins all the time.
The people who have won the most,
also had the most setbacks.
And this is across entrepreneurship,
athletes, singers, you
always suck at the start.
You're always going to have setbacks,
and it's only really a failure if you take
that setback and don't learn
anything from it, and quit.
If you really want to do something,
and you try it and you
fail, it didn't work out.
And then you stop and
say "that wasn't for me,
I'm going to move onto something else".
If that's your habit,
if that's your cycle,
it's going to repeat,
because the first time
we try anything it's not going to work.
The first you tried
skateboarding or you tried
to learn a language or you
tried asking a girl out.
The first time you try anything
is probably not going to work.
It's not going to be great.
And the more you do it, the
stronger your muscle builds,
and the better you get at it.
And so one of the keys
to success in any field
is constant experimentation,
constant trials,
constant errors and
constant getting back up.
If I look at this YouTube
channel as an example,
we have tried more new
series and failed at them,
and left them, than most
people have ever launched.
And we learned from those and
some of them we make better.
If you look at even our Top 10 series,
look at the very first one that we did,
and look at where they're at now.
There's been a lot of improvement.
The clip quality is better,
the editing is better,
the transitions are better,
the intros are better,
the bonuses are better,
everything is better.
It's gotten better with
more experimentations.
And not every experiment works.
And it's been a lot of new
series that we've launched
that we tried a couple
times and it didn't work,
and so we stopped them and moved on
to something else, and learn from those.
If you expect the first
time you put something out
to be amazing, if you
make a YouTube channel,
and you expect your first video to pop,
you're in for a really rude awakening.
It's not how the world
works, and that's okay.
Accept that, get better,
move on, and get back up.
I'm remembered of the
Thomas Edison about how
he didn't fail a thousand
times in making a light bulb,
he just found 999 ways
that it didn't work,
and then the last one that he did,
like would you stick with an idea
a thousand times until you get it to work?
Like most people, they'll try it once,
a lot of people once and they're out.
A lot of people don't even try,
a lot of people just have
the thought in their head
of trying it, and because
they feel like they might fail
they don't even do it, which is crazy.
And then half the people may even do it
and they try it once and then
it doesn't work out so they fail.
And then some people may
try it two or three times
and it doesn't work and they quit.
Would you be willing
to stick with something
a thousand times, and keep testing
and keep trying and keep improving?
Where most people would just
see it as failure and they'll stop.
And most people just quit too soon.
And so just understand that
if you really want something,
if you have a drive, a goal, an ambition
to create something
that maybe is brand new,
has never been done before,
or maybe you're following
in someone else's footsteps
and has been done before.
But if you really want to do something,
and you try it at the start
and it doesn't work out,
that's just step one in your journey.
Don't stop on your path to doing
something amazing that you want to do
just because you didn't
have initial success.
Most people quit way too soon.
Most people quit before they're
going to hit the finish line.
Where you could've had
a great, amazing career,
but you stopped because you were afraid,
and because you didn't
have initial success.
A setback is not a
failure unless you quit.
So the question of today is,
I'm curious, I want to know,
When have you turned a setback into a win?
Talk to me about that process,
talk to me about that experience,
share down in the comments below
and we'll join in the conversation.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Andrew Schultz.
Andrew, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book.
Your one word, it really really
really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying it.
Thank you guys so much for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
Hey believe nation, thank
you so much for watching.
If you want to learn
more about this subject,
get a little bit deeper
on it, I'm going to share
some extra bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- What has been the
best advice you received
from your teacher or professor?
- Ooh I've gotten a lot of great advice
from teacher, mentors,
professor throughout the years.
So first of all, you got to
be open to taking some risks,
and not being afraid to fail.
Failure is the key to success.
So when you get to college,
you got to raise your hand,
you have to be engaged.
Don't be the kid thinking
"well I shouldn't be here,
and maybe I'm not smart
enough, and maybe..."
No, you are more than
capable of going to college,
being successful, and going on to do
whatever you want in life.
I sit here because I am you all.
There is no difference between me and you.
Working class kid, growing up
on the South Side of Chicago,
growing up with doubts and
fears just like all of you.
I know exactly how you all are feeling,
and kids out there who are thinking,
maybe I'm not ready,
maybe I'm not good enough,
maybe I can't afford it.
But what teachers and mentors have told me
is that yes you can, and you must.
So get in there and be bold
with your intelligence.
Raise your hand, get
support when you need it.
And know that we all got here
because somebody helped us.
- I listened to the people who were
successful in selling that product.
I would learn new things
from different ones,
new approaches, you must
be a constant student.
A lot of people are
afraid to try anything new
because they are afraid of
that they will be embarrassed
until they get good at it.
Well on of my favorite sayings is,
the most important thing you can do is to
understand that anything worth
doing is worth doing poorly.
- What do you mean by that?
- Until you can learn to do it well.
My first few sales calls were pathetic,
but I knew it was worth
doing so I kept after it.
My first speeches were a disaster,
but I believed that I
could develop into that,
so I kept at it until I
could do it effectively.
And all skills are exactly the same way.
No running back that sets the records
every set a record the first
time he picked up a football.
And you can go right
down the line with that.
So if it's worth doing,
and you believe in it,
go ahead and fail, and
the more times you fail,
the closer you're getting to
success because you should be
learning on every simple
thing that you do.
- I am not here for me today,
I'm here for every one of you all,
because I kept going, because
I knew the day would come
for one day I'd be standing
in front of a group of
children and telling them
regardless of what happens
to your life, regardless of the adversity,
regardless of the
opposition, regardless of
the trials and tribulations,
nothing can stop you.
The only thing that can stop you is you.
No situation, no circumstance,
no piece of adversity
can define your life.
Never let a circumstance define you.
You see I knew something about you,
I can speak from a certain place,
I know something about you
without even knowing you.
I know if you wanted to
come into this school,
and do what you had to do, you can do it.
I know if you wanted
to go into a classroom
and get straight A's, you can do it.
I know if you wanted to go
to college, you can do it.
I know that you can become whatever
it is that you want to become.
But it's like that quote, you can lead
a horse to water, but
you can't make him drink.
You see, I could tell
you all the right things,
I could stand up here
and say a presentation,
but if you walk out of these doors,
and you don't apply it to
your life, what good was it?
You see I'm not so
concerned with you having
dreams, you having goals, I'm
concerned with the process.
Because a lot of people want the prize,
but not many people want the process.
A lot of people have the will to win,
but few people have the
will to prepare to win.
The process is more
important than the product.
And what the process is,
the process is coming
into this building day after day,
giving everything you
got to mold yourself into
the individual that you need to become
in order to make those things happen.
You know the reason you set goals?
The reason you set goals and the reason
you have dreams is not for the outcome.
The reason you have dreams
is to become the person
that you need to become in order
to make them manifest in your life.
You see, young people, the road to success
is constantly under construction.
With plenty of potholes,
with plenty of speed bumps,
with plenty of detours,
with plenty of parking spots to give up.
But just as if you were in
the car with your mother,
you found a way to get
over that speed bump,
around that pothole,
you found a way to get to that detour.
The only thing about life, that
destination may be that goal
or that dream or whatever it is that
you aspire to do with your life.
The one thing that I can
tell you right now man,
I'm not anything special,
but the one thing I can
guarantee you, young people,
and I'm going to leave you with this.
If you don't give, if you don't stop,
if you don't give in,
nothing will defeat you,
nothing will conquer you,
and nothing will stop you.
Never give up, never stop,
never doubt yourself.
You always believe there's always hope,
and there's always somebody
inside you that's stronger
than anything that life can throw at you.